[Music]
hey guys welcome back to off the record
we talking about what up
jerry's here is
i love i love girl because he's dressed
like he works at a movie theater
[Laughter]
i honestly would love to get a hello
kitty tattoo but i don't have any
tattoos
but i want to get um a hello kitty uh in
the style of a money cat
oh sick right that's a really good idea
where would you do it oh no where's
give me an idea because you are on top
of your butt
oh that one that the vibration oh man
funny bone
and i want to get a tattoo too you have
any i don't
i don't know matches oh my gosh do you
have an idea do you have an idea i do
know what i want but i don't know what
it looks like and i don't know where to
put it what do you want
i want a yin yang that's with the sun
and a moon
but i don't know what it's going to look
like because every design i've seen it's
always garbage so i'm like
right on top of your butt i don't even
know if i'm
picking an artist i don't know like i i
would love an under boob
do you want to be very unique have it
right here no
i don't want to go too much and then
also like the placement is also very
like oh it's all been done
right yeah everything's been done it's
not
this hasn't really everything's
literally been done it hasn't been done
right here the toe it's been done bottom
of the foot
bottom of the face it's been done
inside of the lip everything that's
around the [ __ ]
eyelid
every piece of the penis tip
why are is trying to be so different i
actually like the idea of yin yang as
well yeah maybe on the back of my neck i
remember remember that show
that's not been done yet that's the only
thing that hasn't been done i want to
feel like you know i'm at the checkout
counter at
ralph's you know with with the bar code
behind my back did i say barcode yet i
didn't so someone could get and they
were like
i know what you meant a dark angel where
i see the yin yang on the back of
someone's neck i swear
they died
it's like it's been done i want a
dandelion
yeah no no what's the dandelion again
the flower the flower yeah
if you don't know what it is that's what
she calls them though that's what you're
doing all right
um i i really think it's hot when girls
have like underground
right brianna but my test of gravity yo
it's i would have to like lift up
like the baguette you know
to expose it i can't do underboss
they've been tagging more and more over
the years or more especially after like
when quarantine didn't wear a bra for
like eight months
yeah to the toe the nipple go between
the toe when i paint the nail
when i paint the toenail i put a nipple
in between the toes
but now you don't have to get the
separators anymore you say the money man
you know damn and then you have the and
then like the heart you know the violin
at the same time two two stone one bird
do you make marks like a kid that's
growing to see like where how low it's
going
oh [ __ ] that's the tattoo that's the
tattoo
20-21 i wish i measured it from when i
first got boobs
yeah damn it no but they don't sag yet
you have to start measuring one right
when they start sagging no when i'm like
sitting like like this
yeah obliviously when i'm mad when i'm
naked and mad on the couch
that you just bought my [ __ ] tits are
like
down to my [ __ ] knees oh my god well
yeah you're like that yeah
like the little shrimp tail you know
just like that um
but yeah yeah that's it
and i'm gonna storm out um how's your
show going it's good honey
good trouble we're in the middle of
season three shooting um
dude we gotta catch up yeah we catch up
honey yeah we've stopped
middle of season two no it's all good no
wait yeah we got to season two yeah they
finished season one two yeah we're in
season two and then we went back to see
the other one
sexy dance yet yes okay so season two
you're mid season two
okay um and yeah i do a little sexy
dance the tits are out
yeah she looks hot and she actually
nailed the dance too
like tiff is in love with me um don't
tell my husband don't tell my husband
who's your husband you're like you're
like you're like [ __ ] your husband
you're going yeah but what would you do
to her
that was from an episode what do you
want her to do to you
what would you want to do yeah so i got
hella happy too so
swipe up for the patreon if you want the
good stuff so i pop on youtube
yeah read the comments pay the money for
the honey um
but but yeah i can't believe how much
time is flying we're in the middle of
season three
it's airing and we're about to wrap uh
season three in
like you know may and then i'm like did
y'all shoot during kovya
yeah so we started is your show
addressing coping we're not addressing
copies not addressing code
um but we did start in like
september-ish october do you pretend
like covert didn't exist in the show
do people wear masks i've seen shows
where there's like masks and they're
like detectives
yeah yeah so no we're not addressing
kobe so no mass on screen
but obviously behind the scenes i like
that because i feel like i'm in 2019
yeah the good old days oh tbt
actually that's so true because yeah
watching superstar because that's
another show that very funny
very funny and every time because they
do are they are
all around covid yeah and so it does
kind of bum me out a little bit i'm like
i want to escape
right i think that's because everyone's
wearing masks during the whole time yeah
i think that's my that's maybe what it
is because so many shows have done it
already so then it's like well
yeah the escapism of it all and i don't
know i but but yeah i i support it i i
like how cause
we also have our show is so like we're
all up in
every different world you know we're out
doing this blah blah blah it just
would have been um yeah i think for the
sake of storytelling we're sticking with
no covet
and also there's a light at the end of
the tunnel you know what i mean yeah
we're almost there yeah
when like the second half of our our
season premieres in like summer or
something i'm just making all this up
kobe will be in a better place and then
it's like if we introduce people i think
we're going to open by june
i think like listen may it's june i
think summer's going to be pretty
like popping not pop
in but like pop out
okay pop out like nipple yeah nipple i
like it
pop to the point where we get back into
kovit once you pop the fun don't stop
yeah stop right now thank you very much
there we go
huh obviously i don't think we're ever
going back to quarantine and stuff
really yeah a lot of world leaders are
announcing that this is it then they
have
opening up no matter how bad it gets
we're not going back to well
no no no no if it gets bad again people
i don't think it will get bad again
yeah hopefully we don't know because the
vaccines you know
you know people getting shots you know
you gotta think that it's
stopped it somehow right yeah it's
better for sure i mean i think mass will
for sure be a thing like
for years that's the thing that i hope
the sticks when people are sick you stay
at home when you are sick and you have
to go outside of your home
wear a [ __ ] mask protect everyone
yeah my favorite thing is the six
feet apart i don't want no one near me i
don't want i know i just want to stand
like free or post covered like i don't
want no one in my space what do you do
when you're waiting in line for
something and people
still behind you like they're like right
up again that's that's then you go like
this and you go yeah
as long as they're not like standing
like this people do and
then i then i turn and look and i go
okay and i step forward because that's
[ __ ]
what if you don't have space in front of
you then you turn around to them and
then you start touching them
we do offset you know you stand like to
the side six feet six feet six feet
luckily for casey he already has six
feet yeah right yeah yeah he's so
happy if he's a wreck though you're
freaking only if he's a regular
i was actually guilty but he's always
hard though sorry were you saying i was
i was actually guilty of that of being
the guy in the back
we're at the farmer's market um what's
that area called
i don't know melrose trading post
fairfax weird weird area of ellie that i
don't know the name of
uh but then i was a farmer's market
where there's
and then you know when i see meat i go
crazy the barbecue place yeah the
brazilian barbecue place right
so i'm like oh i'm so [ __ ] hungry i'm
oh i haven't had like eight at a
restaurant a long time is the closest
thing because
you can make get the food and just sit
at a table and then so there's a guy
behind me all waiting in line and it's
that thing where like you put whatever
toppings you want and then you get the
meat and they weigh it
and then you get it to go and i was like
literally all up on this guy because
i just couldn't wait to look to get the
meat and then you're all salivated
very sexual this guy turns around and
goes uh excuse me do you think i can
have some space
and i'm like oh [ __ ] my bad but i didn't
realize
how you were the chinese guy that you're
always trying to avoid
i was the guy where like you know on the
freeway this car's obviously stopped and
this car just keeps
going like this yeah cause i just stared
at the meat it was so delicious i have
those moments too i forget
that like oh right six feet like because
i i you know we've
been doing this for over a year which is
yeah in out of this world um but i do
that too sometimes i'm also such a
hoverer
i'm like you know me i'm like what are
you looking at me
i'm a natural hoverer you know so yeah
so six feet
uh you are used to be a mosquito huh you
know i like to suck the blood i don't
know why every single time i
talk to joe the vietnamese accent comes
out why
he just he does that to people got that
he speaks to people with the vietnamese
the mosquito those mosquitoes were out
this
past [ __ ] summer too i always get bit
like you know when you go back to
asia and like you get those big ass
welts oh yeah
like and you slap them on your shin and
they explode with blood what happens in
mexico too
it's huge i get huge tulum had a bunch
of them yep
i need to go to mexico been once
uh in cancun when i was 19. i went to
chichen itza you know i did a touristy
thing
i want to do the touristy thing i've
never been to chichen itza oh [ __ ]
the story is pretty gnarly yeah but i
also want to be in the back of a pickup
with a narcos and a machine gun that
would be really cool
that's for sure joe style you know i
want to get some mexican food i can't
get hit on tick tock we follow some like
uh
some like uh owl
so it means like drowned tortoises yeah
tortoise
is that like a wet sandwich yeah what
sandwich yeah
but there's a lot of mexican food that
are over there that you can't find here
literally just already soaked it's
drained it's drenched
it's like a wet burrito but a wet
sandwich oh my god that sounds so good
[Music]
oh my god what's going on the type of
bread i'm so
why would you wet a sandwich like a
french dip sandwich kind of
oh yeah are there any asian wet
sandwiches would you call me
asian wet sandwiches guys don't really
like sandwiches well what do you mean
you guys
bro those are so [ __ ] worse god bro
what you saying baby
you guys bro i'm about to fly i thought
you stood with us
no no no you're totally fine [ __ ] this
which is like a burrito with rice yeah
what's that the white steamed taiwanese
breakfast
you never had it's like a sticky sticky
sweet rice and inside they have like a
yo-yo
no the chinese donut yeah yeah no oh my
goodness
did some the white stuff like the white
the dim sum one
oh no with the shrimp yeah that is it
like that no no that's that's also
that's lowball gal right is that every
time
oh i used to go you too
just finished languages
chinese burrito with the with the onion
pancake and then you put the beef in the
cilantro
onion pancakes that's good too but not
that that's kind of sandwich adjacent
but it's more like a burrito it's more
of a wrap maybe yeah it's a wrap yeah
sure
it's our answer to a shawarma because a
sandwich to me is like bread
with things and beans okay so bun me bun
mummy but that's an
actual sandwich because you use a
baguette but nothing wet yeah it's all
dried
all dry sandwiches there's no sandwich
in asian oh yeah
yeah with uh chinese
five five spice braised beef with the
with the pancake
not the pancake what about a picking
[ __ ] pacman bread yeah yeah
foul like [ __ ] bowser that's more of
sliders
yeah sure
categories bro it's all subsets of
sandwiches
sliders are considered sandwiches like
burgers are considered a sandwich
wow sandwiches are european things but
sandwiches aren't considered burgers
unless there's a patty right well here's
my question not a question i don't know
how do we feel about the fact that
sandwiches like have to go with chips
and burgers have to go with fries i want
to switch it up sometimes
very true does it happen that way always
yeah that's usually what it's paired
with
i'm like what's your favorite chips oh
favorite chips miss vicky's jalapeno
dude mine is miss vicky's salt and
vinegar i'm down with that that's my
favorite i [ __ ] with it also
rips up your palette for sure you're
like your skin is hanging from the
bottom
roof of yours [ __ ] you if you go to
jersey mike's and they give you a bunch
of waffle fries
what they don't have waffle fries no
that's a good point no that's a good
point that's a good point
you're we're so used to the chips light
and light versus light in heaven no no
you don't like it
it's cold and hot oh maybe that's what
it is
it's soft and crispy you know yeah cause
if you get a hot sandwich you do
sometimes get potato
fries with it yeah yeah yeah like like a
pastrami right and then you get some
fries on the side
sandwich comes with but this pastrami is
warm yeah that's what i'm saying like a
hot and hot yeah yeah and hot hot yeah
yeah yeah like you're not gonna get a
cold cut and then you're gonna get like
a hot
fries that's true like when you go to
the hat you get a pastrami sandwich and
some fries
there might be more culture to have cold
with some hot fries all right let's
switch it up let's spice it up
wait what's everyone's favorite potato
formal potato we got tater tots
hash browns and curly fries potato
wedges baked potato mashed potatoes i
think you got to go
baked potato i love french fries i
really do yeah mojo potato
mojo who's bro what's that one shakies
the discs
it's like oh yeah yeah yeah it gets
fried with the chicken
those are good dude shakey's got such
good chicken yeah yeah and that takes me
back to like the the fundraisers
waffle fries we're gonna do but season
or not season season
like from like carl jr like from denny's
yes carl jr oh my goodness what about
chick-fil-a waffle fries i know you love
those
i know she loves
wait this is not the patreon
no i i think i'm a tater tot [ __ ] doing
through i'm a tater tot [ __ ]
or from one of these like hipster ass
places your ass please please you got
for breakfast lunch and dinner all right
let me ask you this
tater tots or mcdonald's hash brown
flip your world vietnam world
a new fighter has entered the ring
[Laughter]
no
honestly mcdonald's is so [ __ ] good
but we don't question any of it the
chicken nuggets are in two shapes
yeah yeah the louisiana boot yeah
and the rounder one and the round one
what the [ __ ] or if you get one of their
their like uh more artisanal burgers
the the bun has been like tanning in the
sun for like [ __ ]
and it's like shiny you got it you gotta
have a tan bun though
it's all oiled up and lotioned and [ __ ]
because i know you came out of a
microwave how do you have a tan they
sprayed
you know the stuff on it why is it so
good i haven't been trying their newer
[ __ ] have you guys
it's i tried their new fried chicken
chicken chicken sandwich whatever
no we we were talking about this we
stick to what we know for like
my order at mcdonald's is the same from
when i was in third grade yeah
everybody has the same one yeah what is
everyone's mcdonald's order mine is
mine's uh phileo fish uh with extra
tartar sauce yup i do surf and turf
always have the pizza
you fancy chicken nugget and i have to
have a red meat in there that's food
surfacer
if you don't have a red meat with the
flail fish you're missing out bro yeah
cheeseburger extra pickles yeah always
oreo mcflurry if we're feeling you know
yeah grilled onions
and oh that was in and out babe oh
that's a whole different story
in and out double double raw onions and
grilled onions
because she's not kissing anyone yeah
and then the chopped peppers you say and
the chopped chilis inside
the vibe that's how you customize it
they call it the sherry cola when you go
to in and out you're like let me get the
cherry cola
i wish they did uh things like that
where they did it for travis travis
scott from mcdonald's
i like that that was good that was
actually very good what about taco bell
oh my god i love cheesy gordita crunch
that's my that's my [ __ ]
cheesy gorilla crunch i'm sorry tiff um
i'm kidding no no you are not
you are not going to eat that i love you
so much let me ask you so have you tried
del taco oh my god oh here we go
here we go let me say here del taco is a
sleeper bro
taco crinkle cup fries oh yeah that
would have done yeah yeah
i'll [ __ ] take it gotta do the uh
chili cheese one
that's what i'm saying there's only one
thing i like from del taco and it's the
chicken tacos
those are bombs yeah that's what i want
to know i never actually ordered
anything else actually
the french fries are good too yeah you
got to give it a chance nobody ever goes
to delta what do you recommend
yeah what is the recommended tacos i get
the combo burrito i get all
like the quesadilla is pretty awesome
dude but you got to do it fresh
once i get their chili cheese fries and
i get their nachos
they have chili cheese i don't know this
is one time i got a surf and turf
burrito there
and that's the only time i've ever been
and it was delicious like fresh shrimp
right fresh i'm gonna do the new menu
stuff
incarnate see taco bell is cool
yeah it is they have like the the
branding
i mean it is just whoever's behind their
social media i think that's the appeal
we'll talk about ever since the
the little chihuahua ever since then
it's like video games and taco bell
right yeah but then del taco is more
like you go in there on your bicycle
and you only have two dollars yeah and
you [ __ ] you get a whole meal
and i'm sorry baja blast blast bro talk
about wind
it's the
yeah it's just way too crazy for me i
mean it is kind of like what is this
like what is this windex water down
windex i don't know
but that's that explains it perfectly
though low-key
and the color the color is the [ __ ]
window
like drink a little bit split up the
window
yeah yeah if you put some windex and ice
cubes you're like oh yeah that's that's
the
uh the cool thing is
see freeze doesn't match the food though
it's too icy you know
that's like dessert yeah brain freezing
i mean same with mcflurry
that's later i see it for the end make
flurries like by itself
they should just have a mcflurry store
you know i mean like by itself
instead of like a [ __ ] pink pink
berry or whatever
yo every day dude mcdonald's you can
take notes yeah
aren't you guys sponsored by them too
this guy is he was once
a couple times every time i go to
mcdonald's they their mcflurry machine
is never usually [ __ ] liars sometimes
it is
most of the time it's not though well at
least in my area i don't know how it is
like geographically a guy created a
website where you can geographically you
know like software machines
yeah you people over there so you could
there's a website you could go and then
see
where which mcdonald's around you the
machine is actually currently working
really can you send me the link now tiff
it's so high-tech i reported it months
ago
or maybe even a year that's so high-tech
stories there's no room for
disappointment anymore you know i want
to show up i want to
drive seven miles and be disappointed
like good simple days
[Music]
you